- Auf Wiedersehen!
- Auf Wiedersehen! Mach’s gut!
- Tschau!
- Tschüss!
- Bis bald! Tschüss!
- Wiedersehen!
- Oh, entschuldige!
Hallo, hier Lisa Brunner.
Ah ja, die Anzeige im Internet.
Ja, wir suchen immer noch.
Ja, die Wohnung hat eine Terrasse.
Nein, im Haus ist kein Aufzug.
Nein, eine Garage haben wir nicht,
aber komm doch erst mal vorbei.
Einen Moment bitte.
Ein Stift …
Wo ist mein Stift?
Hast du einen Stift?
- Nein, ich hab' keinen Stift.
- Ah. Einen Zettel …
Ich brauche einen Zettel.
- Hier, ein Zettel.
- Danke! Okay … Also – halb vier.
Und dein Name ist Marvin Graupner.
Okay. Alles klar. Bis dann. Tschüss!
Das war ein Bewerber für Nawins Zimmer.
- Bewerber?
- Ja, Nawin geht doch nach Frankreich.
Wir suchen also einen Mieter für
Nawins Zimmer. Er kommt heute noch.
Aber jetzt gehen wir erst mal
zu deiner Tante!
- Die Tür.
- Die Tür. Richtig!